Software unification.
Uh,
so that I no longer care what computing
device I pick up,
whether it's a laptop or a desktop,
whether it's one I own are one in a
public place.
Uh,
whether it has a small screen or a large
screen.
Uh,
I sit down,
identify myself,
I tune in my information world.
Uh,
I get it in the same way on a no screen
computer in a car.
Um,
uniform access across all platforms,
computers,
telephones to my entire information
life.
It's easy to achieve in hardware.
They're hard software issues,
but they should have been solved 15
years ago.
So long from the other side of the fence
is,
um,
if I were to invest in a,
in a new company,
I would invest in some of the companies
that are working on so called digital
furnaces.
Uh,
in five years everybody throws out all
his cds and dvds.
There are larger MP3 players.
A home stereo system is and t v V
systems are integrated and this is a
billion multibillion dollar transition.
As things stand,
it will be Sony and Google,
a Toshiba,
a few with very large companies doing
it.
And they won't,
they won't do it badly,
but they won't do it.
Well.
Uh,
I would invest in,
in one of the small companies that has
imaginative instead of recycled ideas as
to how to make that transition.
Uh,
I,
you know,
the one of the spaces I'm really
watching very carefully is the mobile
space.
And I think that for a long time,
innovation on the mobile platform was
held back by the carriers and their
control over everything and they're sort
of passion to control everything.
Um,
now that we're getting some brands of
phones that are consumer brands that are
popular enough that we're starting to
get the correct kind of a separation of,
uh,
you know,
people say,
I want an iphone or I want to,
I Google phone an android phone,
right?
People start to say those kinds of
things.
Um,
and those are the,
those are the brands they want.
And the carrier is just whoever you give
service from.
And if we can break that,
that,
that control that the carriers have had
over the platform,
then we get the same kind of innovation
that we had,
um,
on computers and the Internet.
People can be building apps and doing
all kinds of crazy things.
And I don't know what's gonna come out
of that.
Uh,
I just know that when you,
when you put together a platform,
people can innovate on interesting
things end up happening.
Uh,
boy,
uh,
I've,
I don't know.
I mean,
I'm obviously looking forward to what's
going to happen in media and the way
that people consume a content.
That's what I'm most interested in.
So,
um,
clearly the whole idea of mobile in the
idea that you are carrying around with
you,
a screen that can go with you and know
where you are and know who your friends
are,
uh,
utilizing that kind of a technology to
immerse yourself into the world of a
narrative is something that I'm most
interested in.
How to create narrative that,
um,
that helps people understand what their
places in the world and how to make the
world a better place.
So those kinds of technologies are most
interesting to me.
You know,
again,
right now I'm interested,
I'm interested in as a storyteller in
uh,
in trying to use narrative to,
to promote good in the world.
So I'm interested in companies that are,
uh,
that are philanthropic by nature and are
trying to um,
uh,
to promote,
the greater good.
So,
um,
technology that's designed to make the
world a better place.
Uh,
it's,
it's the most interesting to me.
I think what I've heard is a lot more
disruption going on and that's exciting
because it means there are new
opportunities.
It's frightening too,
but I find optimism and excitement in
disruption
kind of on a,
but I think that the answer might be
that the streamed web is important.
We thought the web was about content
like ours sites and pages,
but I think now we see with twitter and
rss and email all adding up,
it says new streamed live web and it's
going to be hard to get used to that
next never ending web of content.
Well,
I think we're going to have great new
ways to interface with information.
And you know,
that's on normal desktop and laptop
computers,
but also mobile devices.
And I think we'll see much more
interactivity in the way we interface
with things.
And we'll see much more richness in the
communication between the computer and
humans.
Oh Gosh.
I don't have a specific company.
I know some directions I would,
I would bet on,
I bet on,
uh,
interactivity moving forward a great
deal.
I bet on applications replacing or
supplementing documents for describing
things for content.
So I think we'll see media outlets
produce very active content in the
future that,
that readers can kind of interact with.
So those are some,
some of the directions that I think will
be exciting.